yes
it's happening finally here damn
straight
been campaigning for the save daredevil
campaign i don't know if you guys
participated in that i sure as hell did
if you follow me on instagram or the
community page you'll know
show my support for this charlie cox's
daredevil
is my favorite mcu character i know some
people give me crap about that but it's
true
he has been and i'm just so happy
daredevil saved
i mean it's still in like rumor
territory
it's technically right i think so
i think come on they haven't come out
and just been like
yes this is all i mean just like they
haven't with toby maguire and any number
of other people but it seems like enough
people
are talking about it it seems like it's
an open secret at this point
i just feel like this
can be one of the biggest mcu movies
in history if they do this across from
the netflix world they're crossing over
the sony marvel characters
with the mcu characters not only with
tom hall and spider-man but then you
also got you know dr
strange in there i thought it'd be a
long time before we got
a gigantic crossover movie within the
mcu
after the events of avengers end game
but it looks like they're already just
swinging into getting there now we gotta
ask the question that's on everyone's
mind
is finn jones coming back finn where
where is
where is iron fist literally do
danny rand we need finn jones back
he's busy he's good so much to do you
know even if you
if you don't get charlie cox what you
get finn jones i'm good with that
that's
is launching next week sign that
petition no i'm wondering about the
other marvel characters too it's like
kingpin is one that i think this would
be a great opportunity to even
introdu like introducing kingpin makes a
little bit more sense
in some way kingpin and spider-man have
a lot of history together and i mean
daredevil and spider-man have also
teamed up but yeah like the
the possibilities seem endless and plus
you can also bring in
like the possibility i know people were
really excited for the potential heroes
for hire
after you know defenders didn't quite
perform as well as shirts and everything
and there were yeah a lot of
remnants of the especially netflix and
i'm sure some of the other outer
marvel properties that fans are really
passionate about now more than ever
seems like if there are a couple
characters who are truly beloved they
can come back and they won't have to be
lost in the void of
rights issues i'm just wondering that if
charlie cox shows up in this you know is
he going to be the lawyer character that
everyone has theorized for a while
it would make sense if he is you know
representing peter parker in some way
or hear me out this is also another
possibility
charlie cox shows up on screen and then
kevin feige shows up
and then he shoots charlie cox and goes
i only did this for you guys
yeah this is all me i didn't want to
meet you i have nothing to do with the
netflix shows that didn't want this in
here
i chose to do this because you i hope
you're happy
yeah it's a smart decision if they bring
them back and also you know like i i
really do think they should remember the
other defenders i have championed that
they should do a defenders movie the
first seasons of most of those shows are
pretty damn good iron fist season two is
better
than iron fist season one in my opinion
but the defenders show i think
unanimously most people were pretty let
down by it and i've thought that
what would be a great way even if you
wanted to do like a send-off with them
if you didn't want to keep it going
it's do a defender's movie with those
characters and even throw punisher into
the mix as well
speaking of which what's going on with
john bernthal is punisher oh dude he's
got
he's like the most beloved like everyone
just accepts like this guy was born
to be the punisher so if he doesn't come
back at some point if disney marvel can
figure out how to incorporate him in a
way that's
true to the character while still
maintaining the grit you know i'm sure
we'll see him again and it's trending
all over twitter right now
i'm excited about this i'm gonna say
hashtag
i wanna almost say we save daredevil but
i feel like in some ways we did
hashtag yousafe hashtag greg saved
daredevil been wearing this loot crate
beanie for ages to the point where
everyone else stopped wearing it but not
me it's a signature
i've always had faith in the [ __ ]
dewey cox i need some [ __ ]
thank you guys so much for being here
hey why don't you subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified whenever i got another
video up who else do you want to see
brought into the
is spider-man 3. you know what i'm
trying to say hit that like button see
you guys